une page théâtrale maintenant avec pour
un certain nombre d'entre vous la
découverte ce soir de tadeusz kantor
l'un des cinq metteur en scène qui
compte aujourd'hui dans le monde
il est à nouveau jusqu'à demain l'invité
du festival d'automne avec un spectacle
d'une demi-heure seulement qui
émerveille le public
un reportage de martine chaussin et de
daniel mailhot tadeusz kantor et
polonais il n'y pas exilé il reste en
pologne
il est néanmoins connu dans le monde
entier et par ses oeuvres picturales et
par son travail de mise en scène avec la
troupe qu'il a créée en 1943 et qui
s'appelait à cette époque sous
l'occupation nazie lequel ce clandestin
expérimental pour devenir ensuite le
théâtre cris qu il présente un spectacle
qu'il a baptisé creek otages en pensant
à collage assemblage d'éléments
empruntés à la réalité sans narration
apparente ce n'est pas là la structure
de la nappe de la narration ceux où
c'est plutôt la structure foie gras qui
sont arrachés on peut dire de la wii
et
c'est dans certain sens c'est la méthode
de surréaliste il y à il y a les moments
de la surprise sur prise de deux sources
qui ne sont pas attendez
qu'il est possible en pologne pour les
artistes de cohabiter avec la loi
martiale est ce que c'est possible c'est
possible à ces quinze jours dans des
tentes
les acteurs jouent de tout fonctionnaire
est ce que vous pensez que l'état de
siège va se terminer avec toi l'état de
siège un peu long il va se terminer
on doit se terminer c'est pas possible
moi même je soulevais qui la guerre
acharnée
c'était la guerre terrible mails même
pendant la guerre 40 44
j'ai fait le test clandestin et que l'un
d'eux ça que je considère comme mon
meilleur période
capa vous retourner en pologne et au oui
ma présence est nécessaire la présence
nécessaire